-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian whose stand-up special
"Cold Lasagne Hate Myself 1999"
was recently nominated
for a Critics' Choice Award.
Please welcome to the show
James Acaster.
How are you, James?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very well. Thank you, Seth.
So good to see you.
-My only regret is that
we're not meeting in person.
Is it safe to assume that
you're Zooming in from London?
-That is not safe to assume.
Actually, I'm in a little place
called New York City!
Make some noise!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But you're not here.
-No, I'm in a little place
called 29 Rockefeller Center.
-Okay.
-That is where I spend
a lot of my time in New York.
I'm loyal to that building.
I will not set foot in 30 Rock.
I'm 29 Rock till I die!
[ Laughter ]
-You have long been
a supporter of 29 Rock.
It's a very overlooked building,
so I totally understand.
-[ Laughter ]
-29 Rock forever.
You can watch "Sunday Night
As Live," my favorite show.
It goes out every week.
Hey, congratulations
on your special, which I adored.
It is chock-full of jokes.
It also talks a lot about
the last few years of your life.
And it's two hours,
and it flies by.
You must be pleased
with the fact
that it was nominated
for a Critics' Choice Award.
-That's very kind of you.
Yeah, I am very pleased, excited
about the Critics' Choice Award.
Also, you know,
I like to get my hopes up.
It came out the same year
as "Inside," by Bo Burnham,
so I can just chill out
and let whatever happens happen,
which I think we know
what's gonna happen.
The last special
I released was 2018,
which was the same year
that Hannah Gadsby released
"Nanette."
I have a rule
that I only release specials
when geniuses completely
reinvent the genre.
And then that's when
I drop something.
'Cause the pressure is off.
-One thing I would say,
none of them
have anything on you,
as far as coming up with a title
as inventive as yours.
How did you come up with
this title?
Because I don't think anybody
else, any other comedian,
would have dared
called a special this.
-They wouldn't have dared.
They're all too scared.
And, unlike me, they didn't have
the experience that I had
when I had a microwave lasagne,
and it was hot
and it tasted rubbish.
So I put it in the fridge,
then I watched "Queer Eye"
and I got drunk,
and then at 3:00 in the morning,
I was so drunk and teary
after watching "Queer Eye"
that the idea of eating
the cold lasagne
was actually appealing to me.
I ate that.
It was the most delicious thing
I've ever tasted.
Like, all the béchamel sauce
kind of congeals
and has a foamy Haribo
sweet texture to it.
It's very good.
And then I got on a text group.
It was 3:00 in the morning.
No one else is awake,
so I've got to do a solo.
They're my favorite times
to go on the text group,
is when you get to do a jazz --
Like, just complete
stream-of-consciousness solo
and tell them everything
that's on your mind,
but not in one block.
In loads of little short jabs,
each thought
as it occurs to you.
And I just was like,
"Cold lasagne is delicious!
It's the best thing ever!
This is the happiest day
of my life!
The best year of my life
was 1999."
And then I started going,
"I hate myself.
And I've just realized
how much I hate myself."
'Cause the drunkenness
kicked in.
And then I changed
the group name
to "Cold Lasagne Hate Myself
1999," passed out.
Then the next morning,
my agent texted me, saying,
"We need to name the show,
'cause the tickets
go on sale tomorrow,"
so I just gave them the most
recent name I'd come up with.
[ Laughter ] -
Bravo, bravo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now...
[ Laughter ]
Some who might not know
your incredible work
as a stand-up
might have first discovered
you when you were on
"Great British Bake Off."
You had a -- You were a meme.
You know this now.
-I know this now.
-You know this now.
It was, "Started making it.
Had a breakdown. Bon appetit."
[ Laughter ]
And, now, this was -- you --
I heard you sort of blamed this
on America,
because this was
jet-lag-induced.
-Yeah, I was coming back
from America.
I was jet-lagged.
And then it turned out
to be the first thing
that got me known in America.
Also, what you guys
don't know is,
all the memes that you love
are comedians abroad.
That's what you guys don't know,
is that ---
That meme of the baby?
Just like that?
That is a really edgy comic
from Scandinavia, that baby,
who makes Bill Burr
look like a wimp!
-They're all --
-They're all -- All the memes
are comedians abroad
who you guys haven't heard of.
That's why the memes
are so funny.
-[ Laughter ]
-But, yeah, I was jet-lagged,
so I did really bad on
"Great British Bake Off."
And then when I said to them,
"Started making it,
had a breakdown, bon appetit,"
I was not lying.
That was the truth.
And then you lot laughed at it,
and it was your fault
to begin with,
'cause your country's
too far away.
[ Laughter ]
-You've done a lot
of panel shows in England,
a lot of chat shows.
What was your first talk-show
experience here in the States?
-Ever heard of a gentleman
called Conan?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Conan O'Brien, his name is.
Real piece of work.
-[ Light laughter ]
-Real piece of work.
I'm glad he's off the air now.
I can't remember
what happened to him,
but he deserves
everything he gets.
I went on his show,
and it went bad.
And also, the night before,
I had visited a Mexican
food truck in L.A.,
and I didn't ask anyone
for tips of which truck
to go to beforehand.
And let's just say
that when I was on Conan's show,
doing the stand-up,
some of my insides were trying
to burst into my outsides.
And within --
And bear in mind,
the audience didn't know this,
but they could sense it --
because no laughs.
They weren't on my side.
And then, within half an hour
of being on the show --
and I wish this was a lie --
I went to a steakhouse
and [bleep] my pants.
[ Laughter ]
Like, literally [bleep] my --
Not I went to a steakhouse
and then got scared of,
like, "Oh, what about
when that airs?"
I literally did a [bleep]
in my pants.
Like, it came out of my butt
and into my pants.
The last place
I wanted it, Seth.
-[ Laughter ]
-Last place I wanted it.
I wanted it either
to stay in my butt
or to find a new home
in a toilet.
I didn't want it
in the pants I was wearing,
which, by the way,
in the U.K. is underwear.
But in this case,
the [bleep] got on both.
So actually, to be fair,
it was a moment that
translated across the ocean.
-Yeah.
-I [bleep] --
I [bleep] both things.
And that's Conan's fault.
And I'm glad that he's now --
I'm glad that he will
never be on TV again,
because his show
made me [bleep] myself.
-Well, I think one thing
we can agree on, I hope,
at least in your estimation,
this has gone better than that.
-Yeah. Oh, I'm here.
And you can't see,
'cause it's like this,
but I am just sat on the toilet
just in case.
-[ Laughter ]
-Better safe than sorry.
-Fool me once, Seth.
-Hey, thanks so much!
I really do hope
next time is in person.
-I do, as well.
You're a lovely man.
-James Acaster, everybody.
"Cold Lasagne Hate Myself 1999"
is available to purchase
on Vimeo.